bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau du numéro du statut de culture
et tout de suite le sommaire de ce
mercredi à 20 décembre
plusieurs dates rock et toujours des
artistes locaux en première partie la
batterie de lui entrouvre dévoile sa
programmation pour les mois de janvier
février mars avec comme toujours
l'éclectisme comme fil rouge jacques à
plaisir aussi on commence l'année en
musique un spectacle bon rythme et le
début de l'année 2018
le point sur cette deuxième partie de
saison avec vincent besson directeur et
joey starr gaspard proust des festivals
des rencontres l'année 2018 va encore
rimer avec de la culture qu'elle me
lambert nous donnera quelques dates à
noter dans vos agendas
en plateau avec nous justement camille
lambert notre journaliste qui nous
donnera un tout petit peu plus tard dans
l'émission des instants culture à ne pas
manquer dès janvier 2018 mais avant ça
je me tourne vers stéphane hains ridao
bonjour vous êtes le programmateur de la
batterie la salle de musique de
guyancourt et vous venez nous dévoiler
vos rendez vous pour les trois premiers
mois de l'année 2018 avec un retour du
rock sur la scène alors un retour il ya
toujours du rock à la batterie bien
évidemment mais c'est vrai que le
dernier trimestre enfin le trimestre
précédent pardon
était peut-être un peu plus métissé avec
la musique du monde du reggae un petit
peu moins de rock et là sur janvier
février mars puisque nous avons une
programmation au trimestre en effet un
petit retour de du rop on va peut-être
développé avec vous sur les différents
rendez vous le rock c'est un style qui
attire principalement à la batterie
c'est un style qui fonctionne qui
fonctionnent assez bien oui en effet
c'est pour ça que suivant les les
tournées des artistes
il ya des certains certains artistes qui
nous font attendre un petit peu donc
notamment une jeune femme dont on va
parler qui devait déjà venir il ya
quatre ans qui finalement ça s'était pas
fait voilà ça dépend un peu des
opportunités et puis il faut négocier
les cachets est enfin là alors le
premier rendez vous ça a débuté en
janvier c'est un petit peu particulier
parce que vous proposez un after work
oui alors ça c'est une opération qui est
mise en place par notre restaurateur
puisqu'en fait au sein même du pôle
musique est aussi un restaurant que
certains saint quentinois connaissent
pour le fréquenter ou le midi où les
soirs de concert et donc avec notre
restaurateur on avait on avait décidé
tous les jeudis de faire des rendez-vous
after works et on les anime nous
l'équipe
l'équipe de la batterie avec le
restaurateur 1 jeudi
par mois sinon c'est le premier jeudi du
mois avec des animations musique est
donc ça peut être nos enseignants qui
viennent qui investissent le restaurant
la semaine dernière il y avait de la
musique baroque par exemple donc c'est
assez décalé mais bon voilà c'est ça le
duo en janvier vous aurez dévoilé le
projet en vie en fait c'est pour
présenter la programmation
aux personnes qui fréquentent qui
fréquentent l'équipement avec projection
de vidéos et la petite nouveauté par
rapport à la dernière fois c'est qu'on
fait un petit show case avec un des
artistes locaux qui se produira au mois
de mars son frère parti de magyd cherfi
c'est cet ebook ces bons justement un
petit mot peut-être sur lui c'est de la
pop du reggae durable aux orties bout il
a un petit peu mixer toutes ces
influences parce qu'il a il a démarré
justement plutôt dans la famille reggae
il a beaucoup
il ya beaucoup joué avec notamment des
musiciens de la vallée de la chevreuse
et donc la maintenance qui propose c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt de la chanson c'est
un petit peu dans le pour les gens qui
connaissent basse bas c'est un petit peu
dans l'esprit de bazbaz une chanson un
peu métissé de son reggae par moments
voilà c'est un album assez bien produit
là ce qu'il a ce qu'il a sorti puisque
c'est distribué chez les disquaires et
sur les plateformes de téléchargement
donc je vais proposer de venir faire
quelques morceaux 20 minutes pour faire
découvrir ce qui sera le 10 mars avec
magyd cherfi et avant qu'on continue de
discuter cette programmation je propose
d'écouter un extrait de thibault
retardataires
je suis un voyage décalage horaire perdu
en mer je cherchais qu'elle s'en
retourne la terre alors thibault lui
sera le 10 mars en première partie de
magyd cherfi l'ex-membre de zebda
il ya d'autres groupes à découvrir bien
sûr sur toutes les dates il ya notamment
french connection un groupe français
bien aux influences anglo-saxonnes
oui c'est vrai qu'on essaye de mettre en
avant aussi la scène locale et régionale
donc les french connection ils sont pas
de saint quentin en yvelines mais ils
vont venir faire une résidence chez
notre cinq jours avec l'arcadie qui est
l'organisme culturel de la région ile de
france
donc ils vont travailler pendant cinq
jours au mois de janvier et ils
présenteront leur concert en première
partie de mademoiselle k
donc ça c'est le février voilà c'est ça
cette voie là
donc moi je crois beaucoup dans ce
groupe il
en fait c'est un projet qui a juste un
an les musiciens s'est avéré plutôt des
musiciens de studio est donc là ils ont
ils ont sorti un album avec d'ailleurs
un très joli objet un vinyle qui est
distribuée chez certains disquaires
parisien et est donc là le but de
l'opération c'est vraiment les faire
travailler on va faire venir un
scénographe aussi pour qu'ils puissent
alors malheureusement sur sur la
première partie de mademoiselle k comme
elle un dispositif technique assez
important ils pourront pas complètement
s'exprimer mais bon ça leur permettra
qui leur servira je pense qu'on écoute
ce que ça donne
vous là
et
or vous le désirez french connection ils
sont français bien oui mais là ma douche
aussi bon soit les saint quentinois
l'honneur il ya nos repas démord pas
bien oui oui mais les bibis ça fait ça
fait dix ans qu'ils et qu'on essaye de
trophées date en commun donc ce n'est
pas d'accord sur la tête d'affiché
et là on est on est tombé d'accord
puisque en fait ce sera avec romain
humeau qu'est le leader du groupe eiffel
et donc c'est vraiment ça c'est dans
l'ambiance un peu de noir désir
et baby c'est un petit peu aussi ses
influences a donc ils sont assez copain
avec romain humeau puisqu'ils ont fait
plusieurs parties plusieurs premières
parties déjà de de sl donc là on est
tombé d'accord la seule chose c'est
qu'on aura un plateau à trois groupes
donc de montbazens de bibis ensuite des
anglais qui s'appelle the jack et et
romain humeau pour terminer la soirée
merci c'était fermé là on est un peu
pris par le temps allant bien sûr
c'était pas exhaustif du tout pour
connaître la programmation de la
batterie direct sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran ou rendez
vous à l'afterwork du 11 janvier saint
quentin en yvelines et ses alentours
c'est plus de vingt salles de spectacles
et de cinéma difficile parfois d'y voir
clair camille lambert vous avez repéré
quelques dates à ne pas manquer chimie
bonsoir mélanie est justement 2018 ça va
commencer très fort avec joey starr à
versailles le 24 janvier
alors comme on ne connaissait plutôt
chez mtm avec ma benz ou laisse pas
traîner ton fils des titres qui ont
marqué les années 90 et le début des
années 2000 je suis sûr ça parlera aux
plus nostalgiques
cette fois il a troqué la plume de la
rue pour celle de l'assemblée nationale
victor hugo robespierre aimé césaire
simone veil de grands noms de l'histoire
et de la littérature que joey starr fait
revivre sur scène dans une production du
théâtre de l'atelier
le rappeur restitue des grands discours
prononcé dans l'hémicycle au fil des
siècles des paroles fortes qui résonne
dans une voix contemporaines cette voix
si reconnaissable de joey starr alors
éloquence à l'assemblée dans un lieu
emblématique le théâtre montansier cette
fois en parallèle en cours avec pour
faire aussi un peu d'humour avec gaspard
proust qui lui revient pour un nouveau
spectacle une nouveau spectacle c'est le
nom justement qu'il a donnée il sera
joué aussi fuir le 6 février au prisme
et on regarde tout de suite un extrait
tu avais moi je suis de la génération
mitterrand
ces générations tout était possible
bernard tapie était ministre
de gauche
c'est comme si madoff écrivait les
discours de mélenchon à peu près puis
mitterrand à l'époque il s'allier pas
avec les écologistes ont coulé leurs
bateaux dans les ports dans le pacifique
alors pour son deuxième spectacle
l'humoriste va encore plus loin dans la
provocation
il s'attaque à tout et tout le monde
femmes handicapées enfants politique ou
personnes âgées
personne n'était pas renié c'est en tout
cas ce que nous promet le prisme et il
faut avouer ça fait du bien aussi de
rire de trouve alors en mars saint
quentin en yvelines sera marquée par des
rencontres entre des chercheurs et des
artistes
les rencontres et une cité du 17 au 25
2e édition de ce festival organisé par
le théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines spectacle
danses conférences et musique autour de
la même thématique l'humain demain le
programme a été conçu avec alexei
grinbaum chercheur au laboratoire
philosophie des sciences au cea de
saclay à l'écran vous voyez le spectacle
sans objet mise en scène par aurélien
bory ce sera les 17 et 18 mars au
théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines un combat sans
paroles entre l'homme et la machine
une bataille aux allures de
science-fiction regarder
et certains spectacles se déroulent hors
les murs à la ferme de bel ébat c'est le
cas de syndromes eu les 20 et 21 mars
toute la programmation du festival est à
retrouver sur le site internet du
théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines
merci car c'est bien sûr la hausse et
une proposition non exhaustive mais vous
pouvez retrouver la totalité de la
deuxième saison ce deuxième partie de
saison sur le site internet casque
points ce qui pointent fr
ben l'oncle soul à montigny le
bretonneux le 20 janvier bernard pivot à
maurepas le 10 mars et attrape les
élèves des collèges et lycées de la
ville fouleront les planches de la
merise le 15 mai dans le cadre de
génération lully et justement le 7
décembre les équipes de génération lully
était présente à la maison de la musique
et de la danse de trappes et le soir et
pour montrer l'avancée du projet
regarder lui lycée jean baptiste un
compositeur baroque
il donne son nom au projet génération du
lit un travail débuté en septembre par
le centre de musique baroque de
versailles et les habitants de trappes
un immense travail déjà car au début moi
j'étais papa je pense et je savais même
pas qu'on aurait le projet muhly à faire
pour moi ça me passionne vraiment
j'adore le théâtre donc
3 que c'était une bonne opportunité pour
ba ba chaque semaine donc déjà ça change
des fois on fait de la danse des fois du
chant et des fois du théâtre
alors vous attendez de venir ici vous
présente dix générations lully à débuter
en 2016 avec une découverte de l'époque
baroque période les 17e et 18e siècles
cette année en créant deux heures par
semaine pour monter baptiste où l'opéra
des farceurs ces farceurs imaginait
toujours des moyens de contourner les
interdits en proposant des formes
nouvelles et inattendues en se référant
à cette tradition là nous nous sommes
dit qu'on pouvait arriver à présenter un
spectacle qui raconterait de façon
comique la vie du lit qui montrerait
comme quoi ça fêtait aussi un sacré
tyran pour tous les autres la création
vous fera aussi découvrir les
vaudevilles des petits morceaux de
musique chantée en spectacle encore cinq
mois de travail et les farces à vous
feront rire
oh
heroes
je
c'est là
au théâtre espace coluche de plaisir
cette deuxième partie de saison est
toujours placée sous le signe du
spectacle pour tous près de 20 dates à
rythmeront cette fin de saison
le point avec son directeur vincent des
semaines vincent desmons bonjour bonjour
alors l'année 2018 débutants aux
chansons avec les celles d'un célèbre
artiste français renault puisque le 13
janvier vous plonger dans le petit monde
de renault oui c'est un spectacle que
j'avais vu avignon il ya deux trois ans
qu'il n'avait pas tourné sur le moment
et qui repart sur les routes pour notre
plus grand plaisir
forcément un plaisir voilà comme ça
avait fait tout de suite et s'est
vraiment passé
toutes les chansons de renommée en
comédie musicale donc il ya un fil il ya
un fil rouge qui même une histoire et et
on retrouve vraiment où tu peux tout
l'atmosphère renault et tous les
personnages et tous les passionnés
plus que tout le monde est là
est ce soir et on vous envoie jury
alors dans cette saison vous avez aussi
des classiques parce que à plaisir c'est
pour tous oui oui c'est le propre de la
programmation ici assez d'être le plus
le plus éclectique possible
donc nous avons le cid montée par jean
philippe daguerre
c'est une superbe mise en scène et ça
faisait très longtemps quand je les ai
vus aussi avignon que je n'avais pas
entendu des verts 10 de cette façon
c'est à dire que ce sont des verts mais
vous avez l'impression qu'ils parlent
comme nous donc vous avez la musique du
verre mais par contre vous comprenez
tout et pour une pièce de théâtre c'est
pas mal de tout comprend et sait
remarquablement remarquablement joué et
mis en scène
vous avez du théâtre vous avez aussi de
la musique et des spectacles pour
enfants les enfants ne sont pas oubliés
de jeunes magi jamais jamais on a
logiquement on va voir le rejet licite
dans le désordre on à l'apprenti
magicien on va voir le rêve de
moustiques aussi donc c'est un spectacle
jeune public par mois voilà le mercredi
où quand il ya des vacances scolaires le
premier jour de vacances scolaires dans
un an de vos coups de coeur on a parlé
du si de là tout à l'heure il y as après
une si longue nuit donc là c'est aussi
une pièce de théâtre c'est aussi une
logique de retrouvailles de quatre
jeunes adultes
c'est ça un lien voilà ils ont un lien
parce qu'ils ont tous été ils ont tous
une histoire dramatique jeunes rwandais
juive ya jeunes palestiniens et il ya un
français de tous était abandonnée en
fait ils ont tous été récupérés par une
femme
récupérez pas très joli mot accueilli
par une femme qui a été leur mère
adoptive et cette femme est en train de
mourir à l'hôpital donc ils se
retrouvent pour lui dire adieu et ils
retrouvaient leurs confrontations
histoire c'est c'est totalement émouvant
c'est très très bien joué aussi c'est un
spectacle encore vu avignon et c'est
vraiment un spectacle j'acquiesce même
plus que ça plus que de la finesse c'est
de la tendresse de la bienveillance de
deux de l'empathie et de l'émotion
beaucoup
mais c'est un regard des comme ça bien
sûr
on pleure mais pas de tristesse en
pleure d'émotion ça fait du bien de
temps en temps de pleurer au théâtre
dans votre programmation il ya de tout
vous l'avez dit vous avez des spectacles
vous aimez faire découvrir vous avez
vous découvert l'avion quelques têtes
d'affiché aussi aidé non c'est plutôt
difficile d'avoir des places je suis
clean célarié vous avez olivier sitruk
c'est ça donc c'est toujours le propre
de cette programmation donc edmond
effectivement la sagesse ça cartonne
comme on dit dans le jargon ça marche
très très bien
on a on a effectivement clémentine
célarié et jean pierre cassignard qui
viennent dans darius pareil c'était un
spectacle vu avignon mais là aussi c'est
une histoire très touchante je vais pas
prendre le temps de la raconter sinon
l'interview va y passer complètement
mais c'est voilà ces deux merveilleux
comédien on a aussi de la danse vous
l'aviez vous ayez l'évoqué une pièce de
caisse qui s'appelle le mouvement de
l'air c'est lié au numérique baissé de
la danse et de la danse et à la fois
aussi de la danse et de l'acrobatie ces
deux là c'est de l'art numérique c'est
ça alors là c'est impressionnant de
technique et de beauté est à noter c'est
l'effet numérique mais surtout c'est
fait en live
toute la musique et les effets sont
faits en l'aï pas fait vous avez tout
une tout à fait alors techniquement ces
deux jours de montage
il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
temps pour que tout soit calé en fait
non je parle dévoilé le truc mais il ya
il ya quelque chose qui fait que les
danseurs peuvent intervenir directement
et que ça provoque des effets numériques
sur des écrans géants directement aussi
il ya une musique du monde on va finir
le mois de mai je mets tout dans le
désordre mais voilà ses yeux fermés
voilà etc c'est de la danse arménienne
c'est le rêve de nos montagnes de la
compagnie yeraz voilà superbe aussi
alors là on voyage mais c'est bien le
voyage et la laideur de voir les
musiques du monde danses du monde
on va aussi leur caisse nationale
ile-de-france mais alors là on va tomber
dans la musique classique beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus classique
facile à dire aussi mais ça voilà deux
façons quand même du temps mais ça c'est
le propre de leur caisse nationale il le
français toujours mettre des pièces
classiques assez connu du grand public
est toujours une découverte
ils ont toujours ce besoin et cette
mission d'ailleurs de faire découvrir
des oeuvres pas forcément connus du
grand public
merci vincent prix alors pour découvrir
cette deuxième partie de saison pour
cette année 2010 huit rendez vous sur le
site du tech le théâtre espace coluche
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
pas d'idées pour aller au cinéma pas de
soucis luc beaucourt le directeur du
ciné 7 à elancourt à son idée regardez
alors mon coup de coeur de la semaine
une fois n'est pas coutume c'est un
blockbuster c'est pas que j'aime pas les
blockbusters mais il y en a de plus ou
moins bon on va dire et c'est star wars
8 les derniers jedi que j'ai vu la
semaine dernière
alors moi j'ai beaucoup aimé parce que
j'ai retrouvé le sel on va dire des
trois premiers qui sont aujourd'hui
classés 4 5 6 l'humour des personnages
sympathiques des animaux farfelu qu'on
retrouvait aussi dans des trois premiers
épisodes des effets spéciaux à couper le
souffle
quand même c'est super bien réalisé le
scénario tient la route ch était un
petit peu déçue par le set et là je
retrouve vraiment là comment dirais-je
la verve de star wars
donc n'hésitez pas à venir le voir en
salle il marche un petit peu moins bien
que le set donc il faut absolument
rattraper le retard parce qu'il est
meilleur que le 7 et donc on l'a aussi
les sept jusqu'à la fin des vacances
scolaires
je ne connais qu'une vérité
le temps est venu pour les jedi d'en
finir
nous ne pouvions pas quitter 2010 est
sans revenir un peu en arrière alors
quelles ont été les rendez vous
marquants de cette année
réponse les revoilà sur la scène du
cirano de versailles john paul ringo et
georges presque cinquante trois ans plus
tard les bootlegs beatles rejouer ne
concerne l'éthique
l'année a débuté en musique 2017 a connu
de nombreux rendez vous marquant les
amoureux d'histoire ont pu redécouvrir
le musée de la ville un déménagement et
18 mois de travaux les huit mille objets
de collection dont un nouvel écrin il y
avait besoin de doubler cet espace parce
que celui du musée était devenu vraiment
très restreint dans l'ancien musée
ça fait plaisir de voir un an et demi de
travail de travaux aussi qu'ils
aboutissent et qui aboutissent a
vraiment quelque chose de contre concret
on a hâte que les visiteurs reviennent
et rendre sa vie au musée
une année qui a vu des débuts des
lancements pour plusieurs rendez vous en
février c'était celui de féminin pluriel
un festival pour promouvoir la création
féminine et l'égalité hommes-femmes en
mars dernier versailles grand parc
mettait la french touch à l'honneur
l'agglomération lancé son festival
électro chic un style électro qui a
aussi fait vibrer le vélodrome nationale
il accueillait le deuxième hors série le
marathon de 14 heures de musique
une première aussi au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la scène
nationale lancé ces rencontres une cité
avec pour thème le temps lorsqu'on parle
du temps on pense aussi au voyage dans
le temps hors louve âge dans le temps ce
n'est pas que le voyage physique dans le
temps et qu'il a été imaginé par
beaucoup de réalisateurs mais c'est
aussi en voyage à travers la mémoire à
travers la géologie à travers la théorie
de l'évolution
une saison marquée par la venue de tête
d'affiche la salle jacques-brel de
montigny le bretonneux a vu jouer le
comédien jean claude dreyfus le
multiplexe saint quentinois a connu de
nombreuses avant-premières en février
grand corps malade présentait son
premier film en tant que réalisateur une
tournée d'avant-premières sans un arrêt
à saint quentin en yvelines
impensable pour omar sy le trappistes
était de retour sur ses terres natales
pour présenter knock passage
les passages porte bonheur en devenir à
skywest c'est le cinéma ou jeu où je
venais quand se sécher les cours
il ya mon lycée qui est juste devant
donc c'est une forme de pèlerinage quoi
2017 aura aussi vu partir johnny
hallyday qui s'est éteint le 6 décembre
dernier le rockeur avait un passé avec
les yvelines un tournage des concerts et
quelques années de vie à montfort
l'amaury toutes ses chances
et un rendez vous manqué à l'appel dans
cette rétrospective la troisième édition
du mondial juniors d'improvisation et
c'est la france qui était victorieuse
cette année
retour sur l'événement avec les
principaux concernés une troisième
édition qui couronne les jeunes de
trappes en avril dernier ils deviennent
champions du monde d'improvisation
junior face à eux les québécois de se
dire champion du monde presse
francophone donc pas mondial tout le
monde mais savait que ça fait vraiment
plaisir c'est c'est un trou d'offres je
me rappelle pas tout les impros qu'on a
fait tout un propos que j'ai fait mais
moi j'ai joué le match réel contrôle et
avec les suisses et le match avec les
susciter vraiment cool
le plus marquant pour moi c'était les la
vie à côté donc avec toutes les équipes
en dehors de la scène
des rencontres avec d'autres junior
francophone pour ce troisième mondial la
suisse le québec et la belgique
quatre jours de compétition avec une
soirée de gala
je retiendrai l'image du du match des
étoiles ou ou en fait on a l'ensemble
des jeunes et des organisateurs qui
était sur le plateau le vin l'image de
faim peut retrouver sur facebook un joli
merci et les coaches qui
qui travaillent au quotidien toute
l'année pour organiser entre autres ces
mondiaux la et
et qui ont dit leurs derniers mots qui
ont dit leurs mots voilà de salut de
remerciement au public trappistes une
victoire mondiale à l'image de cette
année 2010 est marquée par des rendez
vous riche en trophées
on peut retenir que c'est l'année où on
a fait le plus de spectacle cette année
de toute l'histoire de la compagnie donc
ça ça reste quelque chose d'assez
important
l'équipe de trappes intercollèges a
remporté le trophée culture et diversité
et que le site mic a été remporté par un
collège de trappes et que en plus cerise
sur le gâteau les épices les adultes
amateurs ont rapporté la baston jovial
qui est un tournoi parisien
voilà donc pour nous c'est une année
assez assez complète à plusieurs niveaux
si l'année 2010 cette touche à sa fin la
saison culturelle de la compagnie
continue avec un rendez vous immanquable
le mondial d'impro junior en avril il
faudra faire ses valises direction le
québec et c'est la fin de ce set 8
culture merci de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve mercredi 3 janvier passé de
très bonnes fêtes